all right so this talk is going to be
asynchronous because it's going to
execute out of order it's going to be
something like when should I use it how
does it work and then by the time you've
seen how it works you'll kind of
understand what it is so my name is
Jesse Davis I work for MongoDB here in
New York City
hi guys yeah as you may know in New York
there's three kinds of food so we have
sub sandwiches pizza by the slice and
omakase which is a word meaning
something like chef's choice it's when
you go into a sushi restaurant and they
give you whatever is good that night so
New York is a crowded place and there's
a lot of scaling difficulties with
serving all the people but each kind of
food has a different scaling challenge
so first of all when you want to get a
sub you go to the counter and a sandwich
maker comes out of the sandwich maker
pool and you both go to the counter and
you tell the sandwich maker what kind of
sandwich you want what ingredients and
you have this synchronous one-on-one
interaction which lasts for the duration
of the entire sandwich making process
the sandwich maker doesn't talk to a
different client doesn't take a break
that person is completely dedicated to
you until the sandwich is done and you
walk away with it at which point the
sandwich maker returns to the pool and
then maybe takes the next client off of
the eater queue so this is sort of like
a
cpu-bound web service where each client
requests requires a lot of computation
but no external resources in order to
satisfy it and in that case you should
have say a thread or a process per
request which handles the entire request
from start to finish before it begins on
another request so this is an example of
the kind of application that does not
benefit from async because there's no
idle time during the course of
completing a client request just use
multiprocessing to handle this problem
there's no advantage to concurrency
whatsoever but a different kind of food
has different kinds of scaling problems
so let's examine pizza by the slice next
so it starts the same you go to the
pizza counter and you tell the pizza
cook what kind of slice you want and the
slices are already made they're just a
little bit lukewarm so the pizza cook
puts the pizza in the oven and waits for
two minutes until the slice is hot at
which point the cook returns the slice
to you hot and you walk away happy
now what happens if there are multiple
clients who all want pizza at the same
time you can't really scale this out by
adding more pizza cooks in the previous
example if we had more sandwich makers
you can make more sandwiches until you
run out of space behind the counter
right so it's like if you have more CPUs
you can serve more requests by adding
more processes here that doesn't work
because most of the time is spent
waiting for the pizza to be hot and the
cook isn't actually doing any work
during that time so there's no point
adding more cooks instead the cook
should be async the cook should be
rapidly switching between various tasks
as they become ready so as a client
comes in the cook asks what kind of
slice do you want as a slice becomes
the cook gives it to the client who's
waiting for it the bounding resource
here is the cooks ability to remember
which slice goes to whom and how long
it's been in the oven the cook has to
remember the state of all of these
in-flight processes so this is more like
a normal web application a client
request comes in the web server looks at
the request makes some external requests
to a database or to an OAuth provider or
some other kind of web service over a
socket and then it has to wait for the
response and this is the kind of
application that benefits the most from
async because if you were to assign a
thread to every incoming request that
thread is going to spend most of its
life just waiting for the backend so
that it can process that back-end result
like the result of a database query or
an Roth transaction in order to be able
to respond to the original client and
send the request back where it came from
so if you have lots of in-flight
operations at once having thread for
each is wasteful it would be better to
have a single process or a small number
of processes that are able to rapidly
switch among various tasks as they
become ready and so this is what async
is for and this reduces the amount of
memory per in-flight operation or per
connection and allows you to scale it to
a larger number of connections per
server oh so the final kind of food is
omakase and in omakase you go up to the
counter with your friends and the waiter
tells the kitchen that people have shown
up and the kitchen doesn't need any more
information than that the kitchen just
starts making sushi and the waiter
brings it from the kitchen to the
clients as it becomes ready and again
adding more waiters would be wasteful
you don't need a waiter per client and
if you did you'd run out of space behind
the counter the same way if you had a
thread per connection you'd run out of
memory it's better to have one waiter
who sees sushi becoming ready in the
kitchen and takes it to the proper
client to the proper time and this is
like a newfangled WebSocket application
if you go to gmail.com and open a
WebSocket connection to Google's server
nothing else happens you're both just
waiting around for new email to show up
and when an email arrives on Google's
side it sends that information down to
you over the WebSocket and since
WebSockets are very long-lived that
means that Google has a huge number of
WebSocket connections open at a given
time it can't possibly support tens or
hundreds of thousands of threads per
server but if it has an async WebSocket
server listening then it can easily
support tens or hundreds of thousands of
clients at once because it's not
spending a thread per each so that's
kind of like when to use it is if you're
serving slices of pizza or sushi you
need a sink and if you're serving subs
don't bother
clear-rite so oh and this problem is
called c 10k for the ten thousand
concurrent clients problem it was
written by a guy named dan Kegel or
Kegel I'm not sure which the papers
maybe eight or ten years old now but
it's still really good and it's worth a
read he says it's time for web servers
to handle ten thousand clients
simultaneously don't you think after all
the web is a big place now and he says
that perhaps in the not-too-distant
future
those who prefer using one thread per
client will be able to use that paradigm
even for ten dozen clients nevertheless
at the current time if you actually want
to support that many clients you're
probably off using some other pair
I'm so that's still true today threads
still aren't as efficient at as async
servers at this kind of problem so this
is what async is for is to handle this
level of concurrency efficiently so
that's what it's for and we're going to
try like a provisional definition of
what is it it's so my definition of
async is that it's single threaded IO
concurrency so you obviously you don't
have parallel computation because you're
single threaded but you can have
multiple i/o events in flight with an
async server and handle them
concurrently async frameworks use
non-blocking sockets we'll see what that
means in detail in a few minutes and it
registers for events on those sockets
with os-level facilities on linux it's
called a poll on bsd it's called KQ
Windows has something called iocp and
the async framework uses an event loop
and twisted it's called a reactor and
the event loop or the reactor
continuously discovers new events that
have occurred and dispatches those
events to event handlers so there are
many other definitions of async that
don't match this but when we're talking
about twisted or node or tornado and we
say that they're async this is what we
mean it's because they fit this
description so there's a new async
framework
it's called async IO and it just got
pushed into the Python 3.4 standard
library it was mainly written by Guido
with about a dozen other people I made a
few small contributions which were the
most exciting could have ever written in
my life it conforms to a pep called 3156
which
describes its its purpose and its
interfaces and async IO provides it's
much like twisted or tornado it's
influenced by both and it provides a
standard event loop so the years the
decades of incompatibility among various
asynchronous frameworks in Python means
that a lot of code has to be written
again and again and again
so like the MongoDB driver had to be
written once for multi-threading and
again for tornado and then again because
I wanted to do it and then again for
twisted and on and on and on a sync IO
is meant to start to unify the various
async frameworks by giving a single
event loop interface and an
implementation that lives in the
standard library it also provides
co-routines and they're amazing and we
are not going to talk about them because
there's no time so to begin with I know
that that's pretty small but we're going
to make an example application and we're
going to build it on async i/o so the
application is just a simple chat app so
we've got two independent web server
pages and they're connecting to the
back-end over WebSockets and you can see
that whenever a message comes from one
of them it's sent to the server over a
WebSocket and the server rebroadcasts it
to anybody else who's connected this is
absolutely the stereotypical async
example there's nothing special so we're
going to walk down through the layers of
how this works the first is a few lines
of my own example code in the
application layer beneath that there's a
WebSocket implementation and here async
i/o follows twisted terminologies so we
have the same idea of a protocol which
decides what bytes to send and a
transport which knows how to send and
receive
bytes so protocol is like WebSockets and
a transport is like TCP and async i/o
provides you with some transport
wrappers so it gives you a way to talk
TCP and it defines what a protocol
should do but it doesn't actually give
you any protocols so the async i/o
that's in the standard library doesn't
even have an HTTP implementation you
cannot make a web server out of it as it
is so it's not batteries included it's
low level if you want any protocols you
have to get them from a third party and
in this case I'm getting a WebSocket
protocol from a library called Autobahn
beneath that is the event loop which is
watching for events and executing event
handlers and then beneath that is the
layer that we won't actually see how it
works
it's the selectors module which is also
new in Python 3.4 and it actually talks
directly to the operating system and
registers for event notifications on
non-blocking sockets so with all of that
said we can now actually start to look
at some code we'll start simple will
import the protocol and the protocol
factory from audubon for WebSockets just
like twisted async io has you create
protocols and then protocol factories
and the factory gives you new instance
of the protocol every time you connect
it to something the next thing we do is
we need to make a subclass of the
WebSocket protocol this is our chat
protocol it has a global list of clients
and it overrides three callbacks that
are defined by Auto Bahn one is executed
when a new client connects and we just
add ourselves to the global list the
next happens when somebody sends us a
and we just iterate through all the
clients and we broadcast the message to
everybody except ourselves and on close
is executed when a client disconnects
and we remove ourselves from the global
list when that happens so that's very
straightforward the final thing we need
to do oh so I buried the lede this is
the promise that I'm going to make to
you in the next 10 or 12 minutes I'm
going to explain to you how it is that
an event on a socket causes on connect
to be executed so this is going to be
the how a sync works part of this talk
is you're going to see how we receive a
connection from a client register for
event notifications and finally cause on
connect to be executed and if we
understand that then we'll understand
how a sync works so the first thing we
need to do is see how a server is
created so that's at the bottom of my
example application here we create a
protocol factory we attach a protocol to
it we get the event loop from a sync I
oh we finally then do the important
thing which is we create the server that
should say let's look at this maybe I
need to narrow my slides they should go
out and die it so the create server it
takes the interface that it's going to
bind to and it's here so now we're a
layer below where we were we're out of
my example app and we're in async i/o
itself in the standard library create
server it creates a listening socket it
binds it to an interface that stuff is
all very standard and not specific to
async so I've just put ellipses in there
the interesting part starts when we call
set blocking false and that tells the OS
for this socket any
operation I attempt should either
succeed or fail instantly but it should
never block so if I call receive on a
socket and there's no data to be
received
whereas ordinarily my thread would go to
sleep until data came in in this case I
receive an exception immediately instead
that there's nothing to read after that
I get the sockets file descriptor it's
just a number and I register it with the
selector so the selector is that super
low level layer that we're not going to
explain but we can see what it does
which is it takes a file descriptor and
on a vent mask and the mask tells it
what events were interested in so we
want to know when this socket becomes
readable because that will tell us that
a new client has come in to connect and
then we register a you can pass in any
data at all as that final argument and
you'll get it back later so what we're
gonna put in our two callbacks a reader
and a writer and one will be executed
when the socket is ready for reading so
that is the except connection which will
handle the event of a client connecting
to us and then the writer is none so
yeah the next step is to look at accept
connection so we've created a survey we
have handed it a protocol it started
listening and now we're gonna see what
happens when somebody tries to connect
to it here it is
we're still in the standard library here
and it takes that listening socket and
it calls accept on it and this doesn't
block because we set it non-blocking and
we're only executed when we know that
there's actually a client at the other
end waiting to connect to us so we can
call accept now and we get a new
connection which represents one end of
the connection to the client
and we set that non-blocking as well
because it's a new socket and we
instantiate a protocol using the
protocol factory and that is the chat
protocol that we defined back in our
application this is the special subclass
of the WebSocket protocol that we got
from Autobahn we passed that into the
transport along with the connection and
the transport there you can see it has
an init function which calls its
superclass and then there at the bottom
it calls protocol dot connection made
and that was what we wanted to see we
wanted to understand how it was that a
client connecting to us on a
non-blocking socket would cause an event
to execute an event handler and so now
we've seen how that happens we're not
totally done yet with how does async
work because there's one part that it
kind of waved my hand about and that was
accept connection how exactly does async
IO realize that a socket has become
readable so to do that we need to look
at the very last line of our example
application which started the event loop
this is like twister twisted reactor dot
run it's looped out run forever and
we're going to look at its
implementation as the final piece of
this explanation so back in the standard
library now here's run forever and as
expected it's a while true loop and it
gets an event list out of the selector
so again this is magic but we know what
it does which is that it returns us a
list of things that have happened or
things that are ready to be examined
events that we told the selector we were
into
rested in and that list comes as a list
of triples the file descriptor the event
mask which tells us what happened and
then that data that we passed in when we
registered which is the reader and the
writer callback
so the next thing there is we unpack the
data to get the reader and the writer
callback and then we check does the mask
have the read bit set that means that
the socket became ready for reading so
we add the reader callback to a queue of
runnable callbacks called ready and then
we do the same for writing does the
event mask have the right bits set if so
then we take the writer callback if
there is one and we add that to the
ready queue finally we've examined
everything in the event list and we
check how many callbacks are runnable so
that's n to do and for that number of
callbacks we pop them off the beginning
of the queue and execute them and this
loop looks weird it should be just like
for callback and ready execute callback
the reason why we check the number that
our runnable at the beginning of this
loop is because these callbacks can be
anything and they can do anything
including registering new ready
callbacks so by the time we're done with
this loop there might be more callbacks
added and it's an important aspect of
async IOT's event scheduling that only
the callbacks that were ready by the
time we reached the bottom of this main
loop are going to be executed now any
that become ready during the course of
this cycle won't be executed until the
next iteration and that makes lots of
things simpler and fairer
so I believe that I have explained how a
sink works a quick review we start a
server the server binds the socket and
registers its file descriptor and tells
the event loop to execute accept
connection when the descriptor becomes
ready for reading then we return to the
application which calls loop dot run
forever run forever finds out that a
client has connected and it calls accept
connection and that calls back into our
application and calls on connect so ah
this is going much faster the night that
I feared such a review async i/o uses
non-blocking sockets which is a means of
telling the operating system not to lock
me if I'm waiting for some piece of i/o
that's not ready there's an event loop
which tracks the association of sockets
to event handlers that are waiting for
events on those sockets and it uses some
operating system-level API to register
for event notifications and that's all
hidden in the magical selectors module
which you don't really have to
understand the event loop uses selectors
to receive event notifications and
execute call backs when those occur so
now we can rien
the wind should I use it question
because we really understand how it
works and what it is now so use it if
you have a WebSocket application because
those tend to have a very large number
of concurrent connections and the same
if you have a slow but high throughput
back-end or just any situation in which
you have a very large number of
concurrent connections but you're not
doing much computation don't use it if
you are doing a lot of computation
because it will add complexity without
much benefit
also anything that you talked to the
does I owe whether it's a database or a
web service
it needs a driver that's written for
your async framework so if you don't
have an async driver for your database
or whatever
don't use async because they won't work
together and you'll get worse
performance than if you just want
multi-threaded and finally it's a little
harder to write so if you don't have
expertise in shop or you don't have the
time to build it just use
multi-threading and save async for later
if you have a WebSocket aspect to your
application then you can mix and match
making a multi-threaded server for some
parts of your application and a
WebSocket specialist server for the
long-lived connections that your clients
give you so that is that I have a minute
or two minutes and 40 seconds for
questions I want to take two questions
and then I want to ask you two questions
so let's go hey Jesse when you mentioned
when you mentioned that it's only
implemented in in Python 3 and it's part
of the standard I thought we had the
answer about why twisted has not yet
been written for for Python 3 and that
the I thought the answer might be
because it's already written in AC Keio
in the standard library but then you
said it doesn't include protocols and I
thought there may be another answer
which is that twist it is now being
written on async IO and they were
waiting for this for the standard to be
stabilized so I don't know their plans
that is one of the things that's going
to happen is that Ace or a twisted will
be able to replace its reactor with the
async IO event loop but I think that the
whole twisted package is also slowly
being ported to Python 3 as well and
it's just big and old and it takes a
long time how well someone who wants to
take advantage of the asynchronous
programming model and who thinks they're
in the yes category
how will they decide between using
native async IO and you
a package like twisted I really don't
know that's a great question it will
depend on what third-party libraries you
want and what kind of performance
numbers come out once they're comparable
question way back there how does this
affect the lives of people who use green
lights orgy event or co-routines so gee
event is supposed to be compatible at
some point with a sync iOS event loop
and that will allow G event and non G
event async code to interoperate within
a single process and not block each
other so that's going to be fantastic
and co-routines I'm not talking about in
this talk so I'm going to ask you guys
two questions number one was the I spent
many minutes on the submarines pizza
omakase
food joke did that help or is that a
waste of time and should I do something
else so useful waste of time I should
use it for something else
oh okay was useful great and the other
question was raise your hand if I
basically answered the three questions
what is it how does it work and when
should I use it so yes I answer the
questions for you and no I did not oh
okay and then abstain okay all right
thank you very much guys